hello friends i'm alana and today i am
playing post
void uh i don't know that much about
this game all i know is it dropped on
steam and that is a very fast-paced
shooter
which i love you're looking at it right
now i kind of do want to give a photo
sensitive warning
to people for this game just based on
the way that it looks i think it's going
to be a lot of images being shot at your
face very quickly
so heads up let's do it
yep yep familiar with a mouse thank you
for that
oh wow the liquid in your idol is your
health oh
where it go
oh my god so
i do want to give you guys the context
that for some reason this game is aspect
ratio
to be like that big on my screen like
genuinely
it's so small and i don't know why
oh my god thank god i am pleased to
report that now the tutorial is done we
have fixed
the game being tiny um so let's
actually jump into it let's go okay
let's see how far we can get
like it is assaulting my eyes i will say
it is really bright
they take like four shots each
[Music]
oh i didn't kill him damn it damn it
damn it i thought that the guy on the
right was
dead but he was not dead all right
let's try again oh that was a head shot
i didn't even realize that i was
supposed to be going for those
i feel like i'm having a little bit of
trouble even like seeing where the
crosshair is oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] missed him um because of the utter
chaos so let me pay a little bit more
attention to
all that
[Music]
there we go that's much smoother up
okay see now we've gotten headshots
things feel good damn
got me
[Music]
this is a really hard game to talk while
playing i'm sorry everyone
i just wanted to check it out you know
because i love this type of thing
um [ __ ] and i am very into it
but i feel like my game of face is the
most intense it's been in the video for
a really long time
we could do better than 16. we can do
better than that
[Music]
come on i need more people to kill
i think that yeah i just need to be less
panicky in my shooting and then i'll be
okay
[Music]
i don't need to spam the button every
time i see them just go for the heads
you know
and then we're all right very explosive
good stuff all right okay okay jump
[Music]
it's an underwater level immediately
okay reload fast switching to weapon to
a shotgun slows down enemy bullets
i'm gonna try the shotgun i think let's
do that
[Music]
i didn't expect whatever that was what
the hell
okay okay i am glad for the shotgun i
will say that
oh my god they're scaring the hell out
of me [ __ ]
don't get stealthy that will have my
chances of finishing the thing
no stealth for me please
what are you and why [ __ ] i was
reloading
damn it all right
give it another shot give it another
shot
[Music]
all right
come on
[Music]
all right i'm feeling good about this
run so far
like almost at the end everybody's dying
getting there gotta kill you [ __ ]
oh
[Music]
i'm not using the slide very much i
wonder if i should be i guess it does
make me go down like hallway
yeah that's nice yeah let's do more of
that i feel good about that let's do
more of that
oh my god okay [ __ ] reload damn it damn
it damn it
[Applause]
i wonder if you even have to kill that
um
i don't know but i'm absolutely gonna
make my mission now to to finish this
game this is so dope
maybe if you guys if you guys like this
gameplay if it gets some views
uh i could i could stream it uh trying
to get through
the whole thing i don't know how long
it's supposed to be but
yeah it's certainly a challenge and it
seems to be generated so
or at least maybe there are like two
different level varieties not like
randomly generated but
come on it's right here okay let's go
back underwater
no shotgun this time change weapon to a
knife hold the slash
i'm going to reload faster because i
think that gets me
all right creepy weird [ __ ]
[Music]
i hate them so much at least the sound
designs not like
devil bag is scary you know just like a
little bit spooky i think i might have
left a guy back there
oh which is my bad i am really just
running through them now i probably
shouldn't be doing that
but turning around always precious
precious time
you know and i ain't got precious time
video game too fast
all right
[Music]
more shooting less reloading change i'm
gonna do the shotgun
that does sound really good though
oh pretty it's mode i thought that it
wasn't
dead i wasted a second there can't be in
this game wasting seconds i'm already
learning that okay
[Music]
all right i think i'm gonna leave it
there um i just wanted to try it really
and just like get my first impressions
recorded uh this rules
and like i said if you guys have
interest in it i will 100 stream it and
try to get as far as i can
uh absolutely love it um yeah let me get
the details for you on steam because i
always like to support
a little guy developer who are you made
by video game
it's called post void we established
that
it is made by ycjc
games uh it from what i can tell it's an
indie game studio made
by two people swedish studio
oh man that's so cool so yeah it's
available on steam
super cool big fan i'm gonna play more
of this